друзі Всіх вітаю Велика Британія
залишається лідером воєнної підтримки
України і для нас дуже важливо тримати
постійний контакт з нашими британськими
колегами власне зараз Вірменія проходить
такий щорічний конференція
консервативної правлячої партії Великої
Британії Наша команда запрошена на цей
з'їзд і це така класна можливість
поспілкуватися з урядовцями з депутатами
з тими хто вирішує зовнішню політику
Британії і визначає от якою ж буде ця
підтримка і фінансова і економічна і
дипломатична Ну і головне військове
підтримка Британії України і от сьогодні
разом з Петром Порошенком ми мали е дуже
важливі і насичені зустрічі з новим
міністром закордонних справ Великої
Британії джеймсом клеверлі який е став
на цій посаді після того коли ілюстрат
обійняла пост прем'єр-міністра великої
брита До речі виступ пані літра
очікується так само на конференції
консервативної правлячої партії і так
само мали дуже важливу зустріч з
державним секретарем Міністерства
оборони які відповідає якраз і веде
питання закупівель військових отакої
допомоги України
алікам шелбреном і це дуже важливі
зустрічі тому що по-перше ми
поінформували наших колег про нагальні
потреби збройних сил України цю війну
виграє артилерія дрони протиповітряна
оборона Нам потрібно більше танків
більше важкої техніки і ми тут дуже
розраховуємо на наших британських друзів
звичайно подякували за ці тренінги за
навчання які сьогодні
інструктори натівські британські
проводять для українських воїнів і
важливо щоб ви вже зараз розпочалися
такі навчання наших пілотів тому що ми
все ще попереду в цій війні і ми маємо
отримати перемогу і ми відчуваємо дуже
сильну підтримку
контраї партії правлячи щодо України
українського суспільства збройних сил
захоплення нашої армії дуже багато
запитань щодо ситуації на фронті власне
так само ми розповіли про унікальний
волонтерський рух який сьогодні об'єднав
всіх українців тому що мабуть немає Ну
жодного українців від малого до великого
який би не підтримували гривні у Збройні
сили України Це також дуже важливо і
маємо такі конкретні пропозиції проекти
щодо і лікування реабілітації
українських воїнів і щодо посилення
військової підтримки також очевидно що
на всіх міжнародних зустрічах ми
використовуємо нашу контакти наш діалог
для того щоб активізувати
пришвидшити шлях України до НАТО не
закликали наших партнерів от підтримати
цю ініціативу щодо заявки України до
НАТО я нагадаю в принципі що Україна
подала заявку до НАТО в 2008 році і
великою помил тоді було не дати Україні
Грузії пдч пройшов час виправляти ці
помилки падачі Україні зараз не потрібно
а от уже зараз розпочати переговори щодо
майбутнього вступу до НАТО це дуже
важливо очевидно що наші партнери так
само звертаються увагу на необхідність
внутрішніх реформ в Україні боротьбу з
корупцією реально а не фасадну е-е не
фасадно реально демократію свободу слова
незалежний сильний парламент ну власне
ці позиції Ми також підтримуємо і будемо
контролювати владу щоб Україна не
скочувалася в бік автократії А ще цікаві
новини зі з'їзду от наступним головою
такої групи дружби і групи друзів
консерваторів до України буде улюблений
британський в Україні політик Борис
Джонсон якого там ласкаво Так у нас
називають Борис джимсонюк І власне це
дуже-дуже символічно тому що
усвідомлюємо що там де Борис Джонсон там
сильна підтримка України
Ми піднімаємо сюди питання з
пришвидшення нашого шляху до НАТО
і Петро Порошенко виступив з такою
ініціативою необхідності посилення між
парламентського вибору тут що має
посилитися Парламентська Асамблея НАТО і
було би дуже добре якби наші британські
колеги ініціювали в рамках
парламентської асамблеї НАТО спеціально
заяву спеціальну резолюцію на підтримку
заявки України розпочати оцей процес
переговорчий щодо вступу до НАТО а люди
підходять на вулицях пізнають Порошенка
впізнають Марію іонову кажуть бачать її
там по 200 часто як і Олексія Гончаренка
як і Іван котлин поштинсадзе це дуже
круто Дякую і через нашу команду
передають захоплення збройними силами
України і бажання Перемоги очевидно що
перемога залежить від трьох факторів
перший - це більше зброї зброї зброї для
наших зсув друге - це пекельний санкції
для Російської Федерації от Важливо щоб
Європа в тому числі Британія не приймали
цих так званих втікаючих від мобілізації
в Росію тому що ця мобілізація вона
спричинила перше незадоволення В самій
Росії от нехай навчаються відкривати
рота І говорити щось своєму режиму
валити свій люди ненависницький
путінський режим а не тікати в
цивілізовані країни тягти туди руський
мир вони звичайно російські олігархи
дуже люблять тратити свої корупційні
кошти Британії в Європі от Важливо щоб
ці статки ці маєтки були заарештовані і
пішли на
репарації Україні яку сьогодні знищує
Російська Федерація а Звичайно дуже
важливо цю особисті контакти особисте
спілкування очі в очі і ми докладаємо
всіх зусиль для того щоб Україна
якнайшвидше перемогла все буде Україна
друзі